nathalie arthaud bonjour
un didier lequien bonjour
merci à tous les deux d'être avec nous
ce matin après deux actualités qui me
concerne particulièrement le lancement
de votre campagne nathalie arthaud avec
un meeting samedi et vous didier lequien
le lancement du nouveau parti d'edouard
philippe que vous soutenez d'ailleurs on
va commencer avec vous lisiez le coin
lequien pardon voyez ce que ce qu'on
pense valérie pécresse du parti horizon
j'ai surtout entendu un réquisitoire
extrêmement sévère contre emmanuel
macron j'ai entendu dire edouard
philippe qu'il voulait remettre de
l'ordre dans la rue et dans les finances
publiques
cela tombe bien c'est mon projet pour la
france je pense que les électeurs qui
veulent l'alternance à emmanuel macron
qui considère qu'il a mis du désordre
dans la rue et dans les finances
publiques voteront pour la droite de
gouvernement
didier lequien comment finalement vous
définissez le nouveau parti d'edouard
philippe est ce qu'il est doux droite
conservateur libéral centriste à ce que
c'est une nouvelle proposition pour pour
2026 nous
je crois que l'ambition de philips et de
la formation politique qu'il propose
c'est de voir loin pour faire bien voilà
c'est le ce qui résume je croise à sa
démarche c'est le positionnement
politique de du parti horizon on peut le
considérer comme plus que son antre
droit je crois que le monde considère
que c'est sur ce plan là qu'il se qu'il
se place l'objectif de edouard philippe
c'est véritablement de créer une
dynamique pour traiter les problèmes qui
ré qui sont encore devant nous parce que
la france est devant des défis majeurs
en termes de désindustrialisation
de redressement des finances publiques
et nous avons aussi au niveau
international des défis majoration
groupe et ses salles ambitions d'edouard
philippe trias nouveau parti politique
certes les partis politiques ne font pas
je dirais ne sont pas les institutions
les plus populaires qui puisse exister
en france aujourd'hui mais une
démocratie sans formation politique ça
ne fonctionne pas donc cette formation
politique à la pour ambition de
rassembler et de proposer une dynamique
de progrès dont la france
dans la france a besoin alors pour le
moment pas de proposition concrète sauf
peut-être sur la réforme des retraites
regardez ce qu'en dit edouard philippe
et puis on vous écoute ensuite nathalie
arthaud
je veux bien qu'on me dise que 67 ans
c'est trop dur mais c'est déjà ce qui se
fait souvent et pour les plus fragiles
et lorsque nous avons proposé l'âge
pivot c'est justement pour corriger
cette injustice si l'on ne veut pas
baisser les pensions ni augmenter les
cotisations la seule solution est de
travailler progressivement plus
longtemps alors nathalie arthaud vous
qui souhaitez porter le combat des
travailleurs quand edouard philippe
avance qu'il n'y aura pas le choix vous
répondez quoi
je réponds que c'est un mensonge
voilà que c'est un choix politique c'est
le choix de ne pas prendre sur les
profits c'est le choix de ne rien
demander à la bourgeoisie à ces
milliardaires qui sont pourtant
richissime voilà c'est si le choix d'un
camp le camp de la classe capitaliste
voilà au moi je suis le cours des
travailleurs est ce que je sais c'est
qu'il y a des des centaines de milliers
de salariés aujourd'hui qui compte le
nombre de semaines et 2 jours qui les
séparent de la retraite parce que le
travail c'est pénible c'est pénible dans
l'écrasante majorité des cas parce que
sur ces dernières années les cadences
elles ont terriblement augmenté la
pression au travail est devenu dingue
dingue il ya eu des suppressions
d'emplois est partout donc en fait on
fait le travail de 2 on voit là on a une
charge de travail de plus en plus
importante et et on peut pas tenir voilà
donc moi je trouve que c'est que que
voilà c'est vraiment un choix de classe
sociale et
pas ce qui me frappe d'autant plus c'est
que vous savez à 62 ans la moitié de
ceux donc qui partent à la retraite sont
déjà au chômage déjà en dehors de
l'emploi alors très clairement repoussé
encore l'âge de départ à la retraite ça
va juste baisser les pensions de
retraite ça va rendre les retraités
encore plus pour moi alors
qu'effectivement on a un vrai problème
de misère aujourd'hui des retraités moi
j'ai entendu ceux qui avaient du mal à
ceux associés à cause de la flambée des
prix dernièrement n'en prenais
confrontés à ce problème là donc il faut
aller chercher l'argent tout simplement
l'argent qui existent dans la société et
franchement je suis révolté quand on
m'explique qu'il n'y a pas d'autre moyen
de faire parce que quand on a l'argent
qui découlait une petite dégouline à un
pool c'est quand même incroyable
à quoi sert-il tout cet argent dit lisa
aller spéculer ou alors avec lui dans
des caprices de riches dit didier le cas
vous vous comprenez c'est cette révolte
de nathalie arthaud en ce qui concerne
le repoussement de l'âge du départ à la
retraite
il faut s'accorder pour dire que la
réforme des retraites elle est
nécessaire c'est à dire sinon le système
il va dans le mur je n'aurais quelques
chiffres il n'y avait cinq actifs pour
un retraité en
1950 il y en a deux sets il ya de foot
dit viens de cet actif pour un retraité
aujourd'hui en 2050 c'est 1,8 actifs
pour pour un retraité donc ce qui montre
que notre système aujourd'hui il y là il
va vers des difficultés majeures ces 330
milliards d'euros par an qui sont
consacrés aux retraites donc le système
il a besoin d'être réformé ça c'est une
scène impensable si on veut le préserver
si on veut préserver la solidarité de
notre système de retraite aujourd'hui
c'est de quoi s'agit-il 67 ans existent
déjà les cadres un quart des cadres a
peut-être partent à la retraite à 67 ans
et 67 ans notamment les femmes qui ont
eu des carrières hachées toute leur vie
elles partent déjà à 67 ans donc le
système aujourd'hui il est injuste et
ils ne font et on va on va dans le mur
donc il faut le réformer ce crédit et
doit phillips et qu' il faut uniformiser
leurs oeufs le système de retraite il
faut revoir l'âge de départ à la
retraite qui a pas dit d'ailleurs 67 ans
il a dit 65 66 67 et c'est par le
dialogue social parle des échanges avec
les organisations syndicales avec les
organisations professionnelles que bien
évidemment ce système doit être réformé
c'est pas le la réforme ne doit pas
venir d'en haut ça doit faire l'objet
d'un dialogue social constructif avec
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux mais
nier la réalité dire que le système il
suffit de faire ce sigle de faire cela
le gac à faucon ça ne fonctionnera pas
le système si on veut le préserver si on
veut faire en sorte que cette solidarité
qui a été voulu par les frères
fondateurs du site un de ses côtés
sociale en 1945 perdure se développe eh
bien il faut que nous réformions notre
système cpt social nathalie arthaud rond
vous allure on vous voit sourire qu'est
ce que vous répondez en quelques mots
avant d'avancer
d'abord tout simplement qu'ils aient 300
milliards consacrés aux retraites moi je
trouve ça très bien et je trouve ça
beaucoup mieux que 300 milliards
consacrés à la spéculation alors allez
faire des voyages dans l'espace vous
voyez où à bien d'autres caprice de
riche donc je trouve ça un minimum que
dans une société eh bien on permette aux
anciens à ceux qui ont fait tourner la
société de vivre ça c'est une première
chose deuxième chose quand j'entends
dire que tout ça se fera par le dialogue
social or là franchement ça me fait rire
ça me fait rire ce n'est pas donc
edouard philippe qui a imposé cette
réforme malgré les manifestations malgré
les grèves et malgré malgré le soutien
de l'ensemble de la population je vous
signale quand même qu'il ya eu un sacré
mouvement contre la réforme des
retraites que emmanuel macron edouard
philippe voulait mettre en place un il
ya eu quand même des centaines de
milliers de femmes et d'hommes dans la
rue et même des manifestations qui ont
dépassé cela en réalité donc quand vous
me dites que ça se fera avec des
négociations avec d un acte tout ça ça
franchement c'est vous moquez du monde
en disant ça vous savez très bien que ça
sera imposée d'en haut comme toujours
alors non non je le redis
c'est pas du tout convaincant vous nous
dites où il ya moins d'actifs pour plus
d'inactifs mais je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure quand dans une entreprise un
salarié se retrouve à faire le boulot de
deux et de trois salariés tout le monde
réalise mesure que la société les plus
productives qu'elle est capable de
fabriquer plus de richesses qu'elle est
plus riche en fait tout simplement donc
moi je suis quand même je suis toujours
étonné qu'on me com explique que ce
qu'on était capable de faire en 1950
après la seconde guerre mondiale après
cette catastrophe qui a été un set cette
guerre cette destruction 1 on comment se
fait-il qu'on ne soit pas capable de
faire aujourd'hui en 2021 alors que la
société est plus riche plus efficace
encore une fois c'est simplement que les
travailleurs qui doivent aller chercher
leurs heures l'heure
leurs revendications ils doivent aller
chercher leur retraite il faudra qu'ils
allaient chercher leurs retraites et
leurs salaires d'ailleurs leurs
conditions de vie en fait c'est une
question de combat ainsi une question de
rapport de force et moi c'est dans ce
sens là que je ferai ma compagne alors
nathalie arthaud vous que vous parliez
de la question du pouvoir d'achat une
question qui préoccupe les français
notamment cette flambée des prix de
l'énergie ces dernières semaines qui
n'arrange rien surtout pour ceux qui
doivent prendre leur voiture a pour
aller travailler regarder la proposition
de marine le pen fait hier
je propose une tva à 5 5% au lieu de 20%
sur l'essence l'électricité le gaz sur
un plein de gazole de 40 litres ça
entraîne 8 euros d'économies dites vous
qu'avec marine le pen présidente de la
république votre plein vous coûterait 8
euros de moins alors didier lequien le
gouvernement a pris des mesures un
temporaire concernant la hausse du gaz
de l'électricité mais rien sur l'essence
pour le moment est ce qu'une baisse de
la tva sur l'essence ou y seriez
favorable par exemple
alors c'est vrai que la hausse des prix
de l'énergie et en particulier des
carburants et une vraie un vrai problème
moi je suis maire d'une ville de 15
mille habitants dans un territoire rural
donc mes concitoyens ont besoin
d'utiliser leur véhicule pour se
déplacer et la hausse du prix de
l'essence c'est pour eux une réalité
qu'ils vivent au quotidien et ça pèse
bien évidemment sur leur pouvoir d'achat
ça c'est la première chose que je
voulais dire et lorsqu'on est maire on
est vraiment au prise avec la réalité du
quotidien cc c'est notre quotidien et
notre réalité de tous les jours alors
oui bien sûr il faut limiter faire en
sorte de préserver le pouvoir d'achat de
nos concitoyens
la hausse des prix du carburant c'est
les pressions qui existe aujourd'hui sur
la production s'est pas de le
gouvernement qui a décidé d'augmenter le
prix des sens c'est la résulte c'est la
résultante de la réalité internationale
au niveau des cours de l'énergie du
renchérissement du prix de du prix de
l'essence donc la seule façon pour un
pacte et je dirais pour intervenir sur
le marché de l'énergie au niveau
national c'est de limiter ces deux
limites et les taxes c'est ce qu'a fait
le gouvernement déjà sur un certain
nombre de produits et moi où je souhaite
en effet que tout soit fait pour
préserver le pouvoir d'achat de mes
concitoyens en particulier des plus
fragiles celles et ceux qui ont besoin
d'utiliser leur véhicule pour aller
travailler notamment dans les zones
rurales dans lesquelles nakheel par
exemple je suis élu nathalie arthaud
fait comment pour les travailleurs qui
doivent prendre leur véhicule pour leur
pouvoir d'achat vous tel est votre
position
il faut augmenter les salaires il faut
augmenter les salaires et il faut les
indexées sur l'inflation réelle vous
savez dans beaucoup d'entreprises par
exemple il ya une indemnité kilométrique
eh bien il faudrait que cette indemnité
kilométrique elle augmente immédiatement
l'a immédiatement en fonction du prix
observée à la pompe voilà ce serait
quelque chose de très simple faire mais
les salariés les travailleurs ne peuvent
pas supporter ce coût supplémentaire
cette flambée des prix de l'essence
c'est tout simplement une baisse de
leurs salaires c'est une baisse de leurs
salaires c'est une baisse des pensions
de retraite en fait et quand on sait que
les salaires comme les pensions de
retraite et comme les minima sociaux
sont bloqués en fait depuis déjà des
années des années
c'est juste insupportable
alors moi je défends cette idée qu'il
faut absolument une augmentation
générale des salaires d'ailleurs que
tout le monde reconnaît comme étant trop
bas il n'y a pas que l'hôtellerie
restauration où les salaires sont
insuffisants c'est aussi dans cet ordre
la santé dans le secteur des ehpad enfin
dans tous ses secteurs qui sont mal
payés très difficile il faut du
dévouement et on n'est pas payé 1 et
donc il faut une augmentation des
salaires en rattrapage des salaires et
il faut absolument les indexées sur
l'inflation subie parce que là vous
parlez du prix de l'essence mais c'est
pareil pour le gaz en fait c'est pareil
soit les matériaux sais c'est une
augmentation générale des prix à
laquelle on va être confronté donc il
faut absolument que les salaires
augmentent
en fonction de l'inflation réelle réel
je le dis bien parce que le gouvernement
avec son taux d'inflation officiel là
ils sous-estiment l'augmentation des
prix bas oui et c'est quand et en fait
il faut que ça soit augmentée en
fonction
et bien justement de l'augmentation des
prix que l'on obtient quand on remplit
son
camp quand on remplit quand on tente on
fait son plein à la pompe à essence
quand on remplit son caddie dans dans
les supermarchés donc voilà et ça moi
j'espère que les travailleurs dans les
entreprises ils vont le mettre vraiment
ils vont le remettre sur la table parce
que là on a quand même démarré l'année
en avec bruno le maire -ministre de
l'économie qui était vraiment très
heureux de nous annoncer qu'ils avaient
des profits très les prix étaient au
rendez vous la reprise est au rendez
vous
donc voilà il ya de l'argent dans la
société
bon et les travailleurs alors et les
travailleurs et bien ça c'est à nous de
remettre le problème sur la table alors
il nous reste quatre minutes je voulais
vous entendre un peu plus sur ce début
de campagne un peu plus générale un but
un début de campagne marquée notamment
on en parle beaucoup en parlent la
présence du polémiste eric zemmour n'est
pas encore candidat voyez cette
proposition qu'a fait hier fabien
roussel regarder
il y a dans notre pays la loi gayssot
qui condamne toute personne qui tient
des propos racistes xénophobes
antisémites moi je proposerai de
renforcer la loi gayssot en rendant
inéligibles des personnes qui sont
condamnées pour racisme pour incitation
à la haine raciale pour discrimination
en fonction de sa religion alors didier
lequitte qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette proposition du candidat pcf à
savoir on veut pas se présenter si on
est condamné pour incitation à la haine
raciale ce quelqu'un on le rappelle un
d'eric zemmour qui a été condamné alors
moi je suis déjà un kiev sur la façon
dont s'engage cette campagne
présidentielle monde manach études c'est
la grande violence qui existe aussi dans
la société mais qui je dirais
aujourd'hui est une réalité dans dans le
débat public ça c'est la premier point
la première chose que je souhaitais dire
maintenant je dirais que aussi tout le
monde a besoin doit pouvoir s'exprimer
c'est le principe même de la démocratie
la france d'eric zemmour c'est pas la
mienne ce que propose eric zemmour ce
n'est absolument pas moi ce que je
souhaite pour mon fils mais je souhaite
pour mes concitoyens
néanmoins je dirais qu'ils l'expriment
aussi ce que pense un certain nombre de
concitoyens donc chacun doit pouvoir
s'exprimer bien évidemment dans le
respect des règles démocratiques des
règles de droit et tout propos
xénophobes antisémites pour contre une
religion propos racistes et cetera doit
bien évidemment être condamner et
sanctionner lourdement d'autant plus
qu'il s'agit d'un responsable politique
d'un responsable public et qui doit donc
de ce point de vue être exemplaire
nathalie arthaud le de la fin ce sera
pour vous en vous appuyant sur cette
propice aux propositions de fabien
roussel
non mais moi je pense qu'il faut
combattre c'est ces idées là qui sont un
véritable poison pour le monde du
travail vous savez moi ce qui me frappe
c'est quand j'entends eric zemmour dire
un que les immigrés musulmans en
particulier puisque son obsession c'est
quand même l'islam sont inassimilables
août et moi je les vois très très bien
assimilé au monde d exploiter un
aucun aéroport aucun chantier de
bâtiment aucun restaurant aucun hôtel
aucun insecte aucune entreprise de
gardiennage de nettoyage qu'une usine
agroalimentaire ou automobile pourrait
fonctionner sans les travailleuses et
sans les travailleurs immigrés ils sont
très très bien assimilé ils font les
boulots les plus durs
les plus mal payés c'est ça la réalité
alors moi j'ai une chose à dire c'est
qu'ils contribuent mille fois plus
fonctionnement de la société
quelqu'un comme zemmour
merci à les alésiens dernier mot non et
moi ce qui me choque c'est que au
contraire en plus de cela non seulement
de créer des richesses de travailler dur
de payer des impôts des cotisations ils
ont même pas leurs moyens
discutons même pas le droit de vote
merci à vous nathalie arthaud d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin je le
rappelle candidate à la présidentielle
2022 deloutre ouvrière et merci à vous
didier lequien maire centriste de dinan
et soutiens d'edouard philippe